Now there's one more thing you have to do before we end this lesson. As I said
before, it's really important to know how to use technology. And that's why we
had you create a Google account, so that we can easily share real data with you
to analyze. I asked all my co-workers here at Udacity how many Facebook friends
they have, and then I put this data for you in a spreadsheet. Open this
spreadsheet, and then copy and paste the data into a new spreadsheet. And then
try and find the average number of Facebook friends. I'll help you get started.
In any of the blank cells, we always start our calclulations with an equals.
There is already a built in function called average that calculates the average.
See you can write this and the spread sheet software will recognize that you are
going to take the average. Then in parenthesis write your start cell which is
the letter and then the number that corresponds to the location of that cell.
For example c32. Then you'll put a colon because you want to include all the
cells in between the start cell and the end cell and then finish it off with
your end parentheses and then push enter or return. This should give you the
average. Once you find it using the spread sheet tell us what you found. What's
the average number of Facebook friends that my co-workers at Udacity have?